今日は外れ社長ですね最近ガザガチャにすごいなんか気を張っててすごいガチャがある
という話を聞いてそれをちょっと買ってきました
えっと名前は出たし金なんだけど長いがあるんですよねえっと
名前がねぇ尺でプラネットだそう
しゃくるプラネットっていうしゃべれブラーてったっていう方があるってどんなに方
片方取って com
いたんですけども動物なんて動物のフィールなってるガサガサなんですけども全部の
動物がしゃくれててアド鐘江後エコー立ってるんですよ
粘らつないだ何が面白いんで覇者クエぷらねっ
ネーミングセンスしゃくれぷらねっていうことがあるんですけども
あのね聞いてくれアホれを買うおすごい大変だったよイトーヨーカドーが近くにあるん
ですけども喋っターフインターネットでしゃくれプラネット売り場って調べて調べたら
俺んちの近くの伊藤様カードならしゃくりバンディットは売ってるよって言われたんで
僕はしゃべれくらいだったら欲しかったんでイトーヨーカドーでしゃくれプラネット2
月はオスに行ったんですよそした
サークルプラネット売り切れです
が2月分結構最近でたんですけど最近出たにもう行けどんだけ探る比べと売れてん
だって話じゃあねもうちょっとパニクっちゃってやばいしゃくれプラネットの手に入ら
ねえと思ってそれプライスで次に近いところ調べたら次はヤマダ電機ますがザコーナー
に行ったらありました通してのしゃくれプラネットか欲しかったので絶対か思ってたの
でそこでも僕の財布にある100円玉全部使ってしゃくれプラネット8
素を買ってきましたイトーヨーカドーで売り切れてたから絶対人気なんですよみんなね
咀嚼れた動物が欲しすぎて社会現象に連絡で外して全6種類なんですけどかぶることを
考えて8国会ましたねを注ぐ
借家プロネット開けていきましょういやー wn
んだ
なんだ今の謎の圧力を感じたさ
釣り酒でいきましょうパッケージとかちゃんと見てなかったんでどんなしたけれ
プラネットかったるかっ
すっ2人目は今どこでコアラ加奈子は中当たりましたパッと見普通の方なんですけども
よ僕が見るとこういう感じです
うわーっ
また頭痛が何なんだ今日はどんどん上げていきましょう借金でしゃー
工程甲斐あっ匹目はこちらパンダでぱっと見何の変哲もないパンダんですけどもまぁ横
から見るとこういう数ですぅーだ
んがっ
なんだあごは分からないので変な力を感じる今日は次行ってみましょう
イベントもかぶってないからねいいぞ州でお茶次いきます
かぶったやばいもうかぶっちゃったなんてもうかぶっちゃったんですけどやばいよあと
1回してかぶれませんからねっ次行きましょう読んでいきましょう
o chin 厳しい cf 2を普通じゃね at に普通なんですけども横から
見るとしてくれておりますこっちでもそんなに重症ってことでもないですねすごい自宅
でメンバーが揃ってきてますね
ああああっ
に向けああ
なんだ今日はガッツリいきますの後米株がかかぶってもしれないと言えば辛い恋想
キターッ
花育匹見はないよってございます何カジュアルんだよね横から見てもこんなひどい
しゃくれですあと3つでもう12作業する出てるんであと2種類出ればオール
コンプリートでちゃいきましょう
めっちゃ軽い女声めっちゃ軽いよいきます
お次のペットにいる二トリル2人いる中降れだろうシャックで
るみやキャットチャックでるみやチャット文やキャットですねこちらるみやキャット
ですこいつの完全にしゃくれてます良いよあと一種類ですよ
2つだと一緒に行ってたらもうかつですからねじゃあ開けていきましょうあーか
ベッター
ない読んで相撲じゃない不気味だっ
ok すぎるよ重いな思い出していく思いがちな方でコンプリートしたい
多いトイレも全部そろそろあげあではあなたを開けてみようと思います
ん
on
やめてくれ
アルゴなぁ
ハードっ
ドンッあのっいやー
なんだ今のは
なんだこれは
サクサクで亡くなったくーっちょっと挽きさん
あ午後とミクさんが楽タッパ口を出さ
食れているか
魂が移ってしまった護衛ねー
ます
とって
ん
def